spoke about her book running God's Way
step-by-step to a successful political
campaign at Phyllis safely's annual
Eagle Forum collegians Leadership Summit
held at the Heritage Foundation in
Washington DC the program is 20 minutes
our next speaker is Vicky Hartzler and
we're coming down to the practical
approach now that you have all the right
information you should be ready to run
for office and Vicky Hartzler has done
that she served in the Missouri House of
Representatives for six years where she
received numerous awards and coordinated
and managed a number of campaigns she
has a couple of degrees in education
taught consumer sciences for 11 years
and she has a new book how to run for
office and I hope that everybody in this
room is soon going to run for office
please welcome Vicky Hartzler Thank You
Phyllis it is an honor to be here and I
am so excited about the opportunity to
get to share with you how to run for
office and win it's a topic that I is
very near and dear to my heart because I
have a passion for public service and a
strong belief that we need good people
serving us in office at all levels of
government from our school boards to our
county commissions to our state houses
into the White House and it is my hope
that many of you in this room will
decide someday to use your gifts and
talents to serve your community by
running and serving for public office
and so today I'm going to share with you
the top 10 strategies for how to run for
office and win and the first four are
going to be things that you can do right
now to start laying the groundwork for a
successful campaign and then the next
six or things that are winning
strategies for once you file for office
and their keys for you to be able to win
so the first one I'd like to share with
you is some advice that was given to me
when I was about your age
and I was visiting with an older lady in
our community who had been involved in
politics for years and we were driving
to a meeting together and got to talking
about politics and I shared with her
kind of my interest in in that area and
that I might want to run for office
someday and she said to me if you want
to run for office what you need to do
the number one thing is to become an
expert in something very practical but
very wise advice I thought she said
don't necessarily major in political
science I know that many of you are
that's that's great and many people have
served well with that as well but her
point was that most of your life if
you're in elected office it's probably
not a full-time career especially with
term limits and things it'll be first
season of your life and so major in
something that you love someplace where
you can be used to make a difference
whether that be business or education or
social work or agriculture whatever it
is major in that become competent in
that and then use that knowledge to run
on and bring with you to public office
to contribute to society become an
expert in that area and that's one thing
I found in our Missouri House of
Representatives of the hundred sixty
three representatives we really were a
representative of of the government of
the state of Missouri there was people
from all different backgrounds and all
different strengths and it all worked
and that's what makes a great Republic
like dr. Corsi was safe so become an
expert in something in my area as
fellows point out I went into education
and during that time teaching I felt
like I was making a difference for young
people but I was also gaining
competencies that were helpful once I
became elected as helpful I knew about
education so I could help draft
legislation along those lines but also I
had learned how to work with people and
how to organize information and present
it in a compelling way which is
important so find something that you
love become an expert in it and then
bring that strength with you and build
on that when you run for office second
strategy is to volunteer for a campaign
right now to
gained expertise and insights you this
is one of the best ways to learn the
ropes and see if it's something that you
really love and candidates always need
good sharp volunteers and I know they
would just love to have you working on
their campaigns how many of you've ever
voted for a campaign I would bet yes
fantastic and that is fabulous
so you know what I'm talking about
you're learning the ropes you're
learning how to do it plus most
importantly this election here
you're helping make a difference right
now protecting those values and those
things that we hold dear and building
for a strong tomorrow which is your
world so get involved keep up I should
say keep it up the third tip I would
share with you it to start laying a good
foundation is to embrace the concept of
community service now I would imagine
with this room that you probably are
already involved in many organization
and you already have that heart for
community service the best candidates
are the ones who are out there already
giving of their time their resources and
their talents to their community and
when it comes time for them to run for
office people recognize them as a leader
already they recognize a person that has
a heart for service plus they know them
and so they want willing to volunteer or
give their resources or money to that
person to go represent them and do
something that they can not everybody
can leave home and go to the State House
but they will support you doing that
because they know you and they trust you
so get involved and the last thing you
can do right now to lay the groundwork
is more on a personal level but I think
you would agree that it's important and
it's that behave in such a way that
every you would not be ashamed to have
anything you said or did post it on the
Internet because it very well may many
candidates have been waylaid by just one
stray comment
or one ill-advised photo that was posted
on the internet and I have a little bit
of concern for this generation with all
that YouTube myspace Facebook and things
I don't even know about but you do that
are out there pictures have been posted
comments things are being said that may
haunt them down the road 10 20 years
from now they want to run for office
because it'll always be there somewhere
and it potentially could be found and
used against your being embarrassment so
I just say that this group probably
doesn't need to hear that but pass it on
to your friends as you visit with them
and most of all protect your reputation
think long term because your reputation
is one of the most precious things you
have and it'll serve you well in the
future okay now the next six are things
you can do once you've filed for office
that are winning strategies and so
number five would be know why you're
running and be able to say it in one
sentence this is one of the first things
that we had to do at a campaign school
after I filed a run for State
Representative and I know that'll be
easy and it wasn't it took it took a
while and it was an excellent exercise
first of all it makes you really think
through your motives what are you am i
running and then be able to encapsulate
that into one little sentence and that
helps you focus your campaign to what
are my core issues what do I really care
about it's the number one thing that
voters want to know especially if you're
going door to door and saying why are
you why is this crazy person now than
100 degrees on a July day at my door who
are you and why are you running for
office why are you going into politics
there people are curious about that so
you've got to be able to articulate that
when I first ran what I came up with
something like hi I'm Vicky Hartzler and
I'm running to be your next state
representative because I believe there's
a need for ordinary people with morals
and values to get involved with our
government you know pretty simple but it
worked for me then it helped me focus
I was really that's really why I was
running and people appreciate it so
follow that little exercise it'll get
you off to a good start the next thing
you need to do point six is
to raise funds fun fun you've heard that
money is the key that opens the door to
election success and there's a lot of
truth to that
one good thing about the Internet though
is that it is helping to mitigate the
amount of money that is needed to to run
for office because there's so many other
ways to get your message out that is
cost effective but still you're going to
need some basic money to put those up
print out your push card get your direct
mail pieces out you know put your ads in
the newspaper that sort of thing so do
that
prioritize fundraising at the beginning
of your campaign a lot of candidates
want to get right out there and start
going to door-to-door and they put off
the fundraising and then they end up
spending the last month or two before
the election scrambling around trying to
do that when they should be out you know
getting out the vote for themselves so
prioritize that but besides just gaining
money fundraising has an added benefit
of increasing your chances of being
elected because when you ask people to
partner with you in a cause let me back
up there's a right way and wrong way to
raise money you don't ask for a donation
all right oh you don't ask people to
give you money it's all terminology
you're not a charity you're not asking
people first of all they're not giving
you money and you're not asking for
donation you're asking them to invest in
the campaign you're asking them to
partner with you to help bring about
good government and whatever your goal
is common sense government decency in
government it's a shared vision that you
will impart to them and you ask people
to come alongside you to help achieve
this vision and so when people invest
their money in this vision then they'll
have a shared ownership in the outcome
and they will be even more engaged in
your candidacy and what happens they'll
be talking to their friends about it
they might want to give a second time
special if they see that your opponent's
catching up or something they they have
some ownership and they want to see you
win so but raising money isn't just
about money it's about
creating a partnership for a shared
vision and working to achieve that
together okay your seventh tip is to
recognize door to door is king all other
factors being equal the candidate that
goes door to door will almost always win
over somebody that stays home and sends
out a direct mail piece or puts an ad a
newspaper so make sure you establish an
aggressive door-to-door campaign plan at
the beginning and utilize that and that
will increase your chances of winning
the eighth thing is target 8 strategies
target and what image do you think of
when you hear the word target a retail
outlet right shopping yeah okay but put
that one aside what's the other one okay
it conjures up the image of maybe an
archer sighting their arrows on a bull's
eye and then releasing it slowly very
carefully and having it hit the target
with a resounding pin right well in
campaigning targeting is involves honing
in on the people who are going to help
you get elected and focusing your
resources aren't getting them to support
you and that could be done in different
ways you can target door to door where
you establish your schedule where you're
gonna go what neighborhood you're gonna
walk first second and that's based on
voting history of the various precincts
you do an analysis but it makes sense
you target your door-to-door schedule
who am I gonna go visit today and why
you target your direct mail pieces to
audiences that are going to most likely
be interested in that message so for
instance when I ran we said several
different direct mail pieces with
different topics we had one on education
focusing on my background agriculture
I'm also we're farmers so I have that
background so I sent the education
pieces to families or voters who are in
their 20s and 30s you can get that
information is public information from
voter registration so you target those
households assuming maybe they would
have kids and they'd be most interested
in what does she think about education
we sent a gun piece to gun owners we
sent the agriculture piece to the
route addresses in my district so you
target your message to the various
groups there you can also target your
media what newspapers you're going to
put your ads in and want and target your
phone calls maybe forget out the votes
so there's lots of different ways to
apply that but make sure you you target
and you'll enhance your chances of
hitting the mark on Election Day the
ninth strategy is kind of a two-fold
type one and it's to have a positive
message and be able to present it in a
compelling way that through gentle
instruction and that's a biblical term
but it's important as far as a positive
message to not just be against something
but to be for it be the person with the
solution and voters will appreciate that
just don't focus on the negative so how
do you provide the solution through
research researching the issues knowing
the issues the more knowledge you have
as a candidate the more powerful you
will be there's a proverb that I like
that says a wise man has great power and
a man of knowledge increases strength no
the more knowledge you have the stronger
you will be as a candidate and you will
be more competent and more confident
when I was in college I was president of
the student council for my college and
the Dean of our school had a leadership
meeting or conference one day for some
of us and I still remember one thing
that she said I wanted to pass on to you
so I thought makes a lot of sense
she said competence equals confidence if
you want to be confident become
competent and the neat thing about that
is you and I control that we can become
make ourselves more competent in an area
and just the fact that you guys have
spent two days of your summer here
proves a lot about you but you're
becoming competent and issues important
to our country which is going to make
you more powerful when you go back home
and it's gonna make you a stronger
person a stronger leader on campus
because you have that knowledge so when
somebody talks you about there's no
superhighway well let me tell you you
know and the way that you yeah the way
that you do it too is important because
in politics we feel passionately about
issues or hopefully we do and that's the
basis the core of who we are what makes
us tick so when we get to a political
situation so as we meet somebody on the
opposite side and it's easy to start
feeling displaying that passion but that
doesn't usually go very far if you think
about it what changes people's opinions
think about an opinion that you've had
that you've changed
isn't it knowledge information I mean I
could think of several examples I won't
go through them but where I thought of
initially I heard about something like
that's a great idea and then I found out
some more information no I don't I don't
like that at all or the opposite it's
the information that changes people's
minds so as you gain this knowledge and
start sharing it with others either on
the campaign trail or as you work on
campus if you do in a gentle instructive
format to say well I understand where
you're coming from that you know I heard
this and these three things really made
me concerned about that let me share
with you have you heard about there's
this security and part you know
partnership SPP security part oh I've
gone I've lost a P but anyways the
prosperity part the rear thank you
nobody helped me Khan anyway yeah I got
it there we go but anyway share your
three points in an instructive format
it's very effective the tenth strategy I
want to share with you is work harder
than your opponent very simple campaigns
are hard work they involve writing a
campaign plan and recruiting volunteers
raising money you know making your
direct mail pieces going door-to-door
meeting people getting out to vote on
Election Day all those things that are
in my book kind of try to lay it all out
and very easy to understand format so
you can just take your one resource and
put together a campaign but it's
work but I wanted to let you know even
though it's an arduous task it can be
fun too and very rewarding fun and that
you get to meet people you never would
have met before going door to door most
people are very appreciative of people
willing to put their name on the line
and file for office they appreciate that
and they'll be glad to hear why you run
they may not end up voting for you but
they'll respect you for doing it
especially if you do it an honorable way
with integrity and it's rewarding
because you get to have input into
things you care about
and have a say in those things so it is
very important that we have good people
in office and I hope that you will
consider using your gifts and talents
and use those things take the stands
that need to be taken and and be that
future generation of leaders that we
need and I just wanted to close with a
verse that I found when I was in junior
high that minute has meant a lot to me
and I think he has a lot to say about
not just life but campaigns holds true
because it talks about how you can have
favor with man with God talks about
reputation talks about how you can have
success so I just wanted to share it
with you is proverbs 3 verses 4 through
6 in the living bible version and it
says if you want favor with God and man
and a reputation for good judgment and
common sense then trust in the Lord
completely don't ever trust yourself in
everything you do put God first and He
will bless you and crown your efforts
with success so best to you all god
bless you and Kyle have any questions
Thank You Vicki for all that practical
advice and I urge you to get her book we
have copies for you because I'm hoping
every one of you is going to run for
office soon and you won't be starting
out running for president you'll
probably start out running for a local
office and Vicki Hartzler has lots of
good good ideas and good messages and
good advice I think we've got time for a
couple of questions now you have no
questions we covered it all well all
right you're all going to read her book
so then you will have the manual for
action and thank you very much Vicki
Vicki Hartzler a Republican serves in
the Missouri House of Representatives
she's also part owner of Hartzler
equipment company and Hartzler farms
representative Hartzler has been a
junior high and high school vocational
home economics teacher since 1983 for
more information visit eagle forum org